bro yeah sam shanklin with maurice
ashley and indeed that that game he's
made a move did richard and we're gonna
have to get to that
five the seconds are ticking oh a big
time decision
sam's apologies there's just he's got
less than 46 he's got 30 seconds left
and he's got to make a move so we can't
jump away just yet this kind of time
pressure stop thinking i make a move sam
when you see something like this do you
feel any willies or who you're thinking
what what's this guy doing taking so
much time he's got 10 more moves to make
it's just part of the game i don't think
white is in any real danger here to just
if you just play a couple normal moves
you're never going to be worse so
i don't know it seems okay to me all
right he has taken on e5 and we are
expecting to see a quick response there
sam i just because of this time pressure
just one quick moment right here we knew
uh rook takes we we know
the engine points out rook takes e4
is winning for you did you uh is there
something like that of course i thought
about it i'm just trying to figure out
what i missed i mean rookie four is
bishop f5 is it rook h or no because
rook h rook f4
oh rook gg7 there's rook 8 f5
oh that sets
so you missed this point i missed rook 8
takes f5 yeah
that's the one
and then it's gone yeah
that's going to leave a mark
okay well apologies we just were curious
as to what happened you played a fine
game
defending and also coming back in the
game and had a momentary chance yeah i
mean i thought i played him pretty
convincingly at some point i was worried
i was a bit worse at the start of this
end game after bishop takes e4 maybe i
should have not exchanged queens i don't
know but i just thought i sort of
outplayed him without
a ton of trouble and then at the end i i
just missed this detail there's rook 8
takes f5 in this position you examine
all checks and captures back to basics
and i had 10 minutes i could have
thought it
but um
yeah i don't know i was
surprised at how easily it came to me
that black ended up better but did i
miss something before or no
it looked like it was pretty straight
forward this was this was the only
special moment yeah this was the spot
all right
that's really depressing but what can
you do all right well
sorry we have to get going back to the
other game but yeah sure good luck
tomorrow thank you
indeed sam good luck for your final game